luke tom nate and jake here with the
outdoor boys youtube channel and today
we're going to alaska yeah
[Music]
we are going to be in alaska for six
weeks now i have a lot of family up in
alaska so we visit frequently
we've done videos up in alaska back in
2015
2018 earlier this year in 2020
and we are going to do some stuff we
have never done
before survival camping on an island out
in the ocean we're going to land an
airplane
on a glacier we're gonna catch salmon
and remote rivers
we're gonna go kayak fishing we're gonna
explore old military bunkers
but first we've gotta get this family of
five and eight pieces of luggage to the
airport
and fly on a plane for ten and a half
hours oh
[Music]
all right guys
[Music]
[Music]
um
who is this masked man
tommy are you glad to be back in alaska
well we made it to my sister's house
which is conveniently next to my parents
house and we've got the kids fed and to
bed
and it is a beautiful saturday evening
here in alaska and we
are going to take it easy and go to bed
early because we have an
intense and exciting six weeks ahead of
us
i'll see you guys in the morning look at
this beautiful day
now you guys ready to see cousins yeah
all right
now gotta take
your shoes off in alaskan houses
[Music]
you go to taiwan you should need to
learn how to say
did you guys have a good time with
cousins yeah we had a great day going to
church and hanging out with family and
the kids got to play with cousins
but it's bedtime now and poor jacob is
having a hard time understanding
why he has to go to bed when the sun's
shining so much
but i'll see you guys in the morning
we are going hiking camping
and fishing
[Applause]
when i pick it up it's white and when i
kill it on my back
oh
all right guys you ready to go camping
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
here we are guys in portage alaska just
on the other side of the mountain from
whittier
surrounded by mountains and glaciers
we're gonna head through this one lane
tunnel and all the way under this
mountain to the city of whittier
and because it's only one lane there's a
schedule for which direction of traffic
goes at which times
and occasionally they have trains
through there too because there's a set
of railroad
tracks right down the center
whittier is a fascinating town it is
very rainy and in the wintertime it gets
a load of snow
so much snow that if you leave your car
parked outside during the winter time
the snow will crush it like a monster
truck but because of the snow
and the scarcity of land it's just
really expensive to build houses
so most people here live in one
apartment building
up on the hill the last few trips to
alaska we've come fishing here and if
you hit it right
when the pink salmon are running this
place is
amazing look look there's one right
there there's one a couple right there
tommy look the salmon are jumping out of
the water
look at that i don't know if you guys
can see it but there are so many salmon
right there that it's
black there's this massive school of
them and they're just jumping out of the
water every once in a while
look at that but these are pink salmon
and they're really close to spawning so
they've already started to turn
colors so that's not the ideal fish to
eat
salmon tastes best when they're pure
silver
seeing some fish and hermit crabs and
stuff yeah i just saw her
look here's some limpets
you want to eat one yeah there you go
we've got a lot of hiking to do today so
we're going to just keep moving
you okay nathan yeah that happened the
first time
[Applause]
all right guys we're here we are gonna
be doing the emerald cove trail
if all goes well we are gonna get to
camp by the ocean and do some surf
fishing
and uh not get eaten by bears
not really all right
[Music]
it rains a ton here and we're actually
really lucky the weather's perfect today
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
jump out of the line
[Music]
see we're just walking along the coast
trying to get to a deserted cove
[Music]
we gotta cross this little creek
[Music]
give me your hand there you go
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
be
[Music]
yeah looks like the bridge bro
i got wet
look at this
are you relaxing
[Music]
well this looks like a nice spot to camp
tommy over there is just popping limpets
as fast as he can
are you eating limpets yeah me and
lippin
i i only ate one you only eat one little
bit
i must open my knife but i want to eat
everything we have all right should we
get you out of your wet clothes there
oh
[Music]
this is what 9 p.m in alaska looks like
but
the boys are tuckered out and it's past
their bedtime so we're getting them in
their beds and we're going to get them
all asleep
well nathan has already completely
zonked out so we're gonna let him rest
and me and tommy are gonna watch some
movies on our phone aren't we buddy
good morning nathan good morning
well boys you ready to hike back yeah
all right let's do it
mmm ocean snack um
bladder or there's these little bubbles
on the end of the seaweed
and uh it actually tastes good it's kind
of like
salty garden peas
the ants go marching
oh i think we found a deep hole here
here we're gonna get you up give me up
give me a hand
go watch out for that stream here nate
give me a hit
oh
we can see the car we made it oh
my shoulders are a little tender well
you guys want to get some food before we
head back
we've got cotton candy moose flavor and
caribou flavor which one do you want
couldn't pick a more beautiful day today
we got a couple money kids to play in
your house
all right come on hey
here's my jingle oh i
missed my jacob sorry
oh
luke if i see this on your youtube i'll
kill you
all right guys i just got out of the
shower and while i was in the bathroom
my dad brought my donuts
these are wiki wiki donuts right here
check this out
they're so huge oh
look at these things they do not skimp
on the filling here
you're right the pineapple is good oh
yeah pineapple's good
i like these two they're not as greasy
as krispy kreme so you don't immediately
hate yourself after you finish one
morning i am sore and tired
but i've got to continue to post videos
while i'm on this trip
so today is a relax eat donuts and do a
ton of editing
type of day well i'm taking a little
break from the editing to go pick up
some fishing gear
so we're bnjs here we're going to see if
we can't pick up some halibut fishing
stuff
bnjs is an institution it's been here
since i was a kid it's like
our local shop here they have a lot of
commercial fishing gear and sports
fishing gear
oh i love these things so i rented two
rods and i bought a rod and reel combo
and got a bunch of tackle and everything
so this ought to set us up pretty good
for friday
well we've got a hike tomorrow so i've
got to get the kids shoes dried
we're setting the oven to low
seems to be working all right guys you
ready to go hang out with some cousins
[Music]
yeah cookie marshmallow
white chocolate reese's another cookie
i'm good well it's been a lovely day but
we've got to get packed and ready for
tomorrow and i gotta get this little guy
to bed so i'll see you guys in the
morning jacob you enjoying my cereal
yeah no we're gonna cut these in
oh it's coming nate it's coming you
better hold up you can't get switched
you're gonna get smooches be safe and
listen to you okay oh chicken pizza
we're about to get in the car and drive
two hours south to seward
where we are going to be hiking through
the back country to a secret
underground military base where we're
gonna go camping
you know alaska has one of the coolest
traffic laws ever
if you have more than five people behind
you on the highway
you have to pull over brilliant law
[Music]
hey we're in seward alaska and any
minute now
a boat's going to take us off into the
wilderness
where we are going to explore and camp
at an abandoned military base
[Music]
that's leaving us behind we gotta walk
home
we're all alone only way me and nate are
getting back is with our own two feet
how about we go explore a military base
check out this bear den look in here
yep that's black bear poop
hey nathan nathan do you see the
military base
no it's hidden it's right here can you
see it i'll give you a hint it's up
there
can you see it
look at this this down here goes to the
military bases underground
can you go inside of the base we gotta
go find the secret entrance
keep looking in the woods hey nathan did
you spot something
yeah show me show me what you found
you ready
all right
[Music]
look at this
oh this is so cool
what's in here
watch out there's a trapdoor
i wonder if this was like a mess hall or
something whoa
this is so big there's like
look at this there's doors look at all
these doors
[Music]
man this hallway is long look at all
these rooms
this is one of the few that i can
squeeze through
oh look over here we made it out
oh look at this nate look at this
we found it this is where the guns used
to be this is where the giant six-inch
artillery guns were
and look over here resurrection bay
that was cool was that totally worth the
hike
oh look at this
what's in here oh look at this it's a
machine gun nest see look at this they
got these plates that are bulletproof
like this is like one-inch steel
is this cool or what nathan i'm really
having fun
so in case you're wondering the name of
this fort is fort gilvery
and it's on kane's head near seward
alaska
well nathan shall we go back to camp
yeah yeah we got some good food waiting
for us back at the camp
good save dad yeah that tried to get you
his dad had some mad skills thumbs up
for that
on the menu today is a prime well
seasoned one and a half pound
steak with green beans and warm bread
however nathan wants cup of noodle
that's his jam
here try green beans they're good well
nathan it is past your bedtime and we
have to get up early
should we get going to bed yeah
well today was a lot of fun but
tomorrow's going to be a lot of work and
adventure
um i'm going to be hiking five miles
through trail i've never been on before
and three of that
will be across a low tide beach zone and
if we don't get those three miles
covered fast enough
we will be stranded uh and we'll have to
wait 12 hours
for the next low tide to be able to
finish our hike so
no stopping no turning back we're gonna
go to bed get a short night's sleep and
i'll see you guys
in the morning all right nathan you up
yeah you angry at me still a little bit
because i woke up in the night
this is the beach two and a half miles
that way till we get off it
that's it
hmm
[Music]
look at this this is beautiful
tide has turned and is now officially
coming in
that's a starfish oh look here's another
one
yeah he's alive
this is my walking stick walk walk
[Music]
walk
[Music]
that's a chump salmon right there
there's a whole bunch of salmon in here
that's miller's landing where we started
this whole adventure
well we left camp five hours ago but we
made it
i'm tired man of you
there you go
[Applause]
oh my goodness i am so exhausted and
sore but becca and melanie want to go
out and do some stuff
so i'm going to give the camera to them
and they're going to go on a flight zeke
trip
we're going fighting yay
oh i feel so weird we do we're going on
one of those
and we're in moose pass alaska
he's sending me with video he's watching
the kids oh that was
very nice but i have to video it
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
you're welcome well good morning me and
nate are back here at miller's landing
and we
are gonna do some fishing this is gonna
be pretty awesome you ready
yeah all right let's do this
all right nathan you ready to get
started
all right hold on tight
[Music]
i want to do a survival camping video
with nathan
and uh this is the island i want to do
it at i wanted to see it first
looks awesome looks absolutely perfect
oh look at that there's a kilt
[Music]
oh david
we're catching fish
[Music]
all right buddy
[Music]
look at that another greely so i think
we better call it a day
go flare up some of these lovely fish
all right
there we go you guarding those fillets
nate all right
well we got three and a half fish fillet
and the seagulls got the rest
dang it i was sitting there taking
pictures of the fish with nate
and nate goes the seagulls got some meat
and i look over and the seagulls flew
off with three
rockfish fillets jeez
all right back at the house time to cook
up those rock fish we're making
fish tacos
[Music]
all right guys there we go rock fish
tacos
tastes better hey jacob how do you like
your fish taco
good you got that need help
good morning at six a.m and me and tom
are up early to go meet with grandpa
and we're gonna go on a float plane out
to a lodge and we're going to go fishing
for northern pike
rock lou dickinson had one
all right tom hop up on the scale they
do
not like the front should go next
[Music]
[Music]
that's a grizzly bear you want to go see
it you like that tom
so this is the northwood lodge on the
swetna river they do multi-day trips
they do single day trips
like what we're doing they even do
self-guided trips if you want to save a
little money
there's a really nice little lodge here
i wish i'd brought becca and stayed a
couple days
i have an adult universal
just like that oh beautiful oh yeah he
he engulfed that
oh there we go
whoa there we go there we go oh yeah
look at that
i have a son oh there we go oh a nicer
fish
you guys think about that pike right
there hold up oh yeah great fish
didn't miss it because we had click weep
here he comes
yo look at that look at how far he's
coming
yeah that's a boy here we go very loose
casual spitters
how many pike do you think we've caught
so far i mean it's got to be over 20 i
feel like do you not get it
no how did he miss that oh move it move
it move it
oh i just got hit there we go a little
one
oh there you go there you go all right
my back is sore
my arm is sore we have been just having
a ball
curious to see what pike around here are
eating
that looks like a baby pike to me
doesn't it
our plane's here guys we gotta take off
we've had such a good time
tommy is this pretty awesome
[Music]
that's a long vlog here tom
there you go
what is this what's this daddy that's
northern pike
[Music]
all right here we go we got some fish
and chips and fries and we're using the
taco sauce from yesterday too because
it's
you know it's amazing all right guys
well it is late i am sunburned and i'm
gonna go to bed and i'll see you guys
in the morning ah it's a beautiful
morning and we are getting ready to go
camping up until
keaton
all right guys
we're here with phantom river charters
and for a very reasonable price
they will take you and drop you off
various locations
along the river and pick you up whenever
you want and so we
are going to camp all night and fish for
uh silvers pings
chums trout it's it's gonna be awesome
and i think we might be eating some
fresh salmon tonight here we go
oh look at that look at all the salmon
[Music]
here
[Music]
thank you very much we'll see you
tomorrow there goes our ride
our connection to civilization now i
gotta find out where the boys ran off to
you guys having fun
hold it hold it he's taking line
[Music]
how's that
nathan that's a monster
that is a lovely silver look at this oh
it's another beautiful silver oh my
goodness
it is on fire we have gotten two silvers
in five minutes
here walk over here walk to shore
there we go buddy your first silver got
one buddy
oh i think you might have a dolly here
that is a beauty
hold him up there so teeth oh look at
him fight
oh he was crazy
high five that was a heck of a fight
nate another beautiful dying bright
silver
what a wonderful place to fish let alone
camp
huh we got a heck of a night ahead of us
[Music]
well guys i'm gonna be eating barbecued
fresh salmon with corn on the cob but my
boys are a bit more particular so
nathan's got his favorite cup of noodle
and tommy
asked for steak so we got a little bit
of everything for everyone
ugh
fresh alaskan salmon is one of those
fish that's hard to screw up
hands down my favorite recipe is melted
butter
and brown sugar smothered all over a
filet and grilled
oh so good
you go a slab of fresh grilled salmon
and corn on the cob man
oh that was so good
i ate that entire fillet by myself
if you're thinking of coming to alaska
and you're on a budget
the phantom river charter drop-off
service should be number one on your
list of things to do it's probably the
best deal around for catching a salmon
and if you're not confident
enough to do this on your own what i
would recommend is go with their charter
service their normal guided trips at the
beginning of your trip
figure out what's going on get some
confidence figure out what gear to use
what rigs to use
and then come out here and do this on
your own at the end of your trip
kids settle down to bed
all right guys lay down and go to sleep
i think i'm gonna do a little fishing
so this right here is a pink salmon and
there are
thousands of them right in there there
you go
i don't know if you can see this but
there's easily 5-600 salmon in front of
me
[Music]
all right this is why they call them
humpies the males get the big hump on
the back
there we go another pink these pinks are
just in here thick i'm getting hit
almost every cast
but i should get the fire going and get
breakfast made so the boys have
something warm to wake up to
good morning dad yeah you got we got a
little sun on the old back
waking up to bacon egg sandwiches
all right our boats here let's get
loaded up bam bam bam got three as soon
as we
threes we started
holy mackerel we had such a good time
i'll put a link in the video description
to phantom river charter's website
but oh we're sunburned and we're gonna
go get some sunscreen
we have about five hours to kill so uh
we're gonna go into talking and just
kind of see if we can find something to
entertain ourselves
we're here at atv tours and rides in
talkeetna
and we're gonna see if we can't go on a
little atv ride
with the boys and maybe just maybe
tommy will get to drive his own atv you
excited bud
yeah you are you just hop up and wait
and wait for his instructions okay
[Music]
the tricky parts i'm gonna drive and
then the easy parts you're gonna get a
drive okay
all right nathan you ready yeah
[Music]
tommy's doing great
toby what do you think is this awesome
this is so fun are you nervous nope
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
tommy high five yeah
see the beer scratching the wood
[Music]
i'll tell you what there's a lot of atv
tours in alaska but very few that will
let
kids as young as nathan ride along and
even
fewer than let kids as young as tommy
drive was that one of your favorite
things we've done so far
that's my favorite tool we ever done
before
right there number six
i can't wait to see photos
mama brought food yay we settled in
nicely into our cottage now we're gonna
take the kids over to a little
playground and
just kind of relax a little bit holy
mackerel this
is one great little playground
i learned this at school
hey vega
i'm a little wide in the caboose this
doesn't fit me too well
okay this may be the best playground
i've ever seen
it is 5 30 in the morning and are you
guys glad to be up
[Music]
now there we go
i don't know if you guys can see it but
there's probably 500 pink salmon
right here just about 15 feet off the
tips of my fingers
all right oh there we go there we go
there you go
[Laughter]
oh here you go right you got it right
flip it flip it reel it reel it hard
jerk him
buddy keep that remember keep the rod
tip up in the air oh that's a beautiful
fish that's bigger than daddy's
that wouldn't take much
whoa that one's fighting buddy oh he's
he's
freaking out big one
[Applause]
big fish of the day tom you know mom's
caught a bigger silver than i've ever
caught
there you go tom
oh first our first pink salmon
looks almost like a rainbow trout all
right we're gonna let him go
of all the species of salmon we're
likely to catch today silvers are the
most popular to eat
and your limit it doesn't really matter
which salmon you catch you're only
allowed three
salmon so we're letting go the pinks and
keeping the silvers
that's a pink i sure thought it was a
silver
oh it's actually a small pink too on top
of that
look at that as soon as we got grandpa
out of there your bad luck went away
oh no it's a rainbow oh look at that
it's all over grandpa oh good thing he's
got the trout net hand
look at the size of that rainbow here
hold the pelican top oh the
look at look at that oh yeah
that was a beautiful rainbow thomas
all right bud keep feeling yeah it's a
big dolly
[Music]
look at that oh that's a beautiful dolly
that is a beautiful fish it's got these
pink spots on them
it feels like a child he was acting yeah
he was
[Music]
well those chum salmon are just loads of
fun
[Music]
oh we got a double here nate's got a
fish grandma's got a fish
i wanna picture that bucket
yeah it is buddy that's the biggest
salmon you've ever caught over the water
here
nice job all right there we go
dad oh it's a silver this one's probably
gonna get off
there you go yeah yeah pink salmon
good job oh nathan's got one
tom's got another one down there
there nice pink sam you wanna hold him
there we go oh look at the seal wound on
him both boys are fishing for peaks here
it's almost every cast with these i
can't blame them those are loads of fun
and there's loads of them this is eight
number eight
number eight look i have to use a lot of
strength
tommy is this so much fun yeah it is
good job nade that's good right there
look at you lassoed him nate nathan dad
you're tearing them up
a big old buck look at the hump on that
guy look at that that is a
massive massive humpy yes it is
[Music]
all right look at that
keep running buddy
[Music]
this is your 18th pink holy mackerel
oh the beautiful rainbow
gorgeous rainbow
we've probably put 50 fish in the boat
it's
in four hours it's been amazing
that seems about right
[Music]
that is a pile of salmon flesh
i have hunted and gathered yeah you have
tomorrow hello
everybody 97.8 perfect you're cool
well guys we are here at talkeetna air
and we are going to do a flight scene
tour of
mount denali formerly known as mount
mckinley
sit where you like plenty of room what
kind of a plane is it to have an otter
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
wow
all right guys we're here on ruth
glacier about six thousand feet and
right there is the base of denali
highest mountain in north america look
at this
this glacier is thousands if not
millions of years old
so you could be eating wooly mammoth pee
are you eating the glazier
tommy why are you laying in the snow
with no shoes on
it's full of snow stick what
now whoa
[Music]
not too far tommy
[Laughter]
see i'll be pleased to play again
go go
so
[Music]
there
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
while we're winding down for the evening
and i went to the store to get some
dinner
and end up buying loads of nachos and
cheesecake
so uh that's happening well we're
packing up the car while the kids are
playing in the park across the street
and uh we're heading back to anchorage
guys you have fun and tell keatna yeah
[Music]
good sitting on the back deck with
sparkling cider and peanuts this ain't
too bad
i opened it long ways well today is an
easy day i am just working on editing
videos
catching up on sleep and tomorrow's
sunday and because of the quarantine
we've just been doing church at home and
so
just kind of couple unwind days and then
monday
we have got some great adventures we're
gonna head down to homer
we're heading over to my parents house
to do home church
and uh there's a moose right there look
he's right there do you like that moose
[Music]
you want to ride him yeah it is a
beautiful monday morning and
me and the family are packing up and
driving down to homer alaska
we're going to be doing some sea
kayaking and fishing and lots of
adventures
all right buddy you ready to go homer
[Music]
[Music]
we actually rented a cabin here on the
kilcher homestead
which are kind of famous if you're into
reality tv shows
i think alaska the last frontier tv show
is filmed here
we're driving to our cabin and there's a
porcupine
this is not bad at all i get a lot of
people asking me for links to the places
we stay
on these adventures so i'll make sure to
put one in the video description
[Music]
yeah nice view from the balcony when
good weather good views and good porches
all line up
you've got to barbecue what a great idea
it's really good all right see you
tomorrow dan
he's sad he misses cousins all right
guys it's bedtime
well it's just loads of fun to eat out
here in this beautiful back porch and
cook some food with my brother's family
and just relax but it's late now and the
kids are to bed
and i've got to get up early to go kayak
fishing in the morning so
i'll see you guys in the morning all
right i have my brother and his
posterity here in the car
and we are going to take a water taxi to
a lodge
where we are going to rent fishing
kayaks
and hopefully catch a lot of fish we're
doing good
[Music]
[Music]
hello
this is gonna be fun
[Music]
we could catch ourselves sculpin a
couple rockfish
or a hundred pound halibut we just don't
know that's not a salmon joe
i'd really love to catch a halibut
there we
we go we got something going on here
oh we got another sculpin yeah this
one's pretty
it's like a sea robin
another sculpin
lift him up oh he's adorable
sounds like ben just hooked into a big
halibut or something over there
i'm gonna see what's going on
that's a proper halibut that's what a 20
30 pounder yeah
ben congratulations you got a fish dan
why dan what do you have there i thought
it was snagged and then it started
coming up a little bit
but i've been playing it for 20 minutes
and i can hardly get to move up
my my brother's over there playing
around with his fish
probably a snag he's really milking this
for all it's worth
i i think he got oh there he what what
is it a jellyfish
it's it's it's a chunk of sea enemies
about
that's got to be a 30 pound 40 pound
rock
and it's safely released back to the
depth oh
oh there's something oh
[Applause]
it is a trophy sculpin
look at the size of that monster look at
the mouth on him
all right
oh got something bending the rod over
here
it's a baby hell of it my first halibut
from a kayak
oh there we go oh
there that's big enough to eat
this is a flounder look at him
there he's off dang he's going crazy
look at that he got another little baby
halibut
what's that like your fourth fourth
halibut over there
it burns ah
okay this is just sick he's catching
hell of it two at a time now
i think i need to switch gears and go
after some salmon
that way if i can see him
oh jeez there's like a thousand of them
we have a real hodgepodge of fish here
that we've
we've kept a dusky rock fish
a greenling a small halibut
uh pink salmon and uh
there's some sort of cod that's a nice
fish man
that's a really nice fish well that is a
chunk of halibut right there
if you guys want to do this make sure to
look up just add water alaska.com put a
link in the description
to their website but uh we better get
heading back
i don't think i've ever gotten i don't
know
you're having a really fun time it hurts
so bad to carry you
oh i gotta put you becca what happens if
i take 20 of these at one time
oh look at all those berries while we
were out fishing becca and the kids
apparently had a ball
picking raspberries and exploring homer
i'm here with my sister-in-law rebecca
and we're gonna pick raspberries
thank you good job buddy yeah ransom
how's it going
oh good look at the stem the white tanks
are stunned
i tried to get a little bit darker so
far so good
pull it yes high five look at the size
whoa that is a monster it smells so good
yay yay harvest time treated us well
nope nice four pounds
oh
well the advil is kicking in and i'm
loosening up i think
we are going to go for a little walk
there's a culture family homestead
museum down here
and uh you can walk down to the beach
apparently so
we're gonna go check that out
my legs are so gummy already
that was a fun little walk around the
culture homestead
they're still actively filming the
reality tv show here
so they asked us not to film certain
buildings and certain things going on
but uh yeah just a fun little hike with
a walk with the family
and we're out of shape and tires so
we're going back guys check it out
there's bainberry here
i think it's the most poisonous berry in
alaska
i knew somebody who tasted one and spit
it out and they just ended up like
pooping for like three days straight
check this out
see these white berries here's some more
of those berries they start off red
and then they turn on white but these
are deadly poison
[Music]
look tommy bear see him see the black
bear coming back
to the cabin after our walk and there
was a black bear on the lawn and it just
ran off into the woods
the decent sized one well that's the
second bear i've seen today
there are a lot of black bears around
here well it's our last day here in the
cabin and we're heading back to
anchorage
and we wake up and guess who's sleeping
on our porch
okay guys i want to go play with the dog
[Music]
boys are you guys having fun with the
dog yeah
well we solved the mystery of the dog
apparently it belonged to ivan kilter
and
the grandma came by and gathered the dog
we had a nice chat but
we need to pack up and get out of here
and get heading back to anchorage you
guys hungry
yeah let's go get some breakfast
well we're back at the house and i am
getting all my camping gear ready
because tomorrow
the whole family is going camping we're
all packed and loaded in the entire
extended family
is gonna drive about six hours north to
tangle lakes
but we're gonna be doing some camping
[Music]
regular pin
this is a nostalgic place for me we grew
up camping here
almost every summer my other sister my
brother my parents pretty much arrow all
my family that still lives in alaska is
camping here with us so it's gonna be a
fun time
all right let's see if there's many
berry bushes over here
how are you eating them blueberries huh
that's cool
here in the interior of alaska we get a
lot of berry bushes
blueberries crowberries leanden berries
low bush cranberries
i mean they're just everywhere
look how much berries are in my pot oh
man yeah
that's good that's good guys
these tiny little blackberries these are
crowberries
that's a decent amount for hand picking
and that's how much that
all right there's a little bit of
berries shall we go put this on some
cake
a lot of evil very vegan
[Music]
here we go it's a mild italian sausage
green beans carrots onions cilantro
potatoes that's fabulous thank you oh
good oh it's so windy
turn them into a jelly and add
a nice big cup of clean blueberries
you know well it's about 10 o'clock and
the kids are to bed
me and becca are just gonna go for a
little walk
mama were you warm i was very bored
you guys having fun yeah are you warm
yeah
[Music]
from
oh this wind is getting nasty it keeps
knocking the tents over
jumping into bed
[Music]
there you go
well the wind has been wreaking havoc
with our camping
it's been knocking down tents and
causing all sorts of problems so we're
packing it up a little early
it has been blowing 20 to 30 miles per
hour
pretty much non-stop since we got here
and it's been getting worse
it was fun but i am sick and tired of
the hot dogs flying off my plate
and you know anyway we're heading home
[Music]
all right let's check our smoke route
see how she's doing there we go that
smoker's really going
oh yeah all right guys it's the next
morning and the salmon's been smoking
for 24 hours like i i like
jerky style salmon especially since i'm
gonna be transporting it back to
virginia i want it nice and
dry and tight
that'll work now you can see the
difference here this is the pink salmon
and this is the silver salmon this is
the pink salmon we caught
kayaking out in homer so we're just
taking it nice and easy and
i'm getting ready for camping tomorrow
and me and the boys are going to be
going on another adventure but
yeah we're just having a good time
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
we're here at the primrose campground
near seward on the shores of kenai lake
and uh we're gonna do a little camping
here and my wife
and sister are gonna be joining us which
is a special treat
so we're gonna go ahead and get the
campsite set up and get the boys fed
and when they show up then we are going
to go down the shores of the lake
and do some survival camping start
gathering up firewood and put it in the
back of the car
[Music]
almost dies every time we hit the ground
[Laughter]
[Music]
those tears are real people
so i'm gonna try to go do the survival
stuff becca's gonna sleep in a tent with
a cot
and my sister melanie is making an art
form out of car camping
well it's time for dessert and i brought
marshmallows but my sister
also brought marshmallows which one do
you want i want the big one with the big
lemon cookie
i also brought lemon cookies
[Music]
yeah you like that bacon is that good
that's really good well it's getting
late and me and jacob are gonna head off
and go build our survival shelter
you excited buddy yeah i got one now
what do you think should we camp here
yep
you like the tent
okay
there you go yeah you look cozy there's
tickle holes in here look at this this
is great
jacob are you having fun yeah you are
full of energy
how many how many marshmallows did you
eat it's bedtime
what a beautiful morning i wake up in my
sleeping bag and open my eyes
and i see this
squirrels are making their little
warning chatter they don't do that for
moose normally
i can hear sticks snapping pretty big
ones over there
now it's moving over there
there we go an ugly little spoon
dab of butter
hey jake
come on out of the tent and i'll get you
some food okay
i got some oatmeal for you well he's not
coming out got to go in after him
hi jake sit down
that's nice and warm isn't it oh
you want to go see mama now all right
let's pack up
put the fire out and go see mama
well guys did you have a good time yeah
yeah
well you want to go home and ride on a
moose yeah
yeah let's do it
oh we got whales
there's a lot of them out there can you
please keep it down over there
my head hurts oh there's one
two they're kind of gray those might be
pilot whales
i dropped the family off at melanie's
place now
i'm gonna go borrow some hair clippers
i'm getting shaggy oh yeah
okay go down so today we got a little
bit of a weird activity planned we
really wanted a family photo and so
we're doing it
but with an alaskan twist
[Laughter]
we wanted to get a really truly alaskan
family photo and so we hired matt here
with the
photo emporium and he brought hank the
moose here
and we are going to get photos of the
kids on the back of a moose
guys are you having a good time
[Music]
guys that was so much fun if you're ever
in anchorage and you want an
awesome family photo i'll put a link in
the description
to hank the moose
it's another beautiful day and we're
packing for another wonderful adventure
we're taking the entire family
to whittier we're gonna rent a boat
are you guys ready little scurvy sea
dogs yeah
what a beautiful day to go out on the
ocean becca are you excited to get
hypothermia
and seasickness i get seasick
[Applause]
all right let's do this
this is it dad's sealing the boat
we have rented this 22 foot fishing boat
for two whole days
we're gonna camp on it and we're gonna
see glaciers and hopefully whales and
seals and maybe catch halibut or
rockfish or salmon
we can do whatever we want because it's
our boat what do you guys think of this
[Music]
is this beautiful becca you're beautiful
becca
just had a salmon jump in front of us
[Music]
look boys iceberg ahead
there's a glacier that's falling into
the ocean over here
look at this this is just
awesome people rebecca is this cool
this is cool i'm glad i came guys should
we get some ice for the fish cooler
yeah all right let's let's get some
glacier ice
come in
nice glacier ice
how does it taste it doesn't taste salty
though oh that should do it
everyone hold on we're going to cruise
around here and see if we can't uh
find some fishing oh there's a signal
there's something
looks like the rain is relenting for
just a little bit
got a fish jacob take jacob reel him in
this oh how is it cute
[Music]
should we put him back
[Music]
oh we got one oh man oh
oh keep that rod up tom
that is a beauty that's a king salmon
buddy
that's my first one great cake salmon
man
oh so much fish slime shall we put them
in the cooler
yeah or put them on glacier ice
high five dub were you guys hungry
yeah all right let's get some dinner out
here okay we've got we've got mres for
dinner
santa fe rice and beans vanilla pudding
dessert powder
all right got our mres let those warm up
how you like the ravioli
oh tom you got one it's a card a card
yes i caught a card oh it's pooping
it's pooping you got a big one tom
that's a lean cod
what it's a very yummy fish called the
lean cod
look at it look at the teeth on him we
have had an absolute ball
but it's about nine o'clock so i am
going to find a spot over there
to anchor up and uh we're gonna get the
kids ready for bed but uh this adventure
isn't half over
you guys all cuddled in yeah okay
good night okay be good
good morning nathan good morning did you
sleep well
yeah well everyone's kind of taking
their time getting up which is just fine
so i'm gonna
pull up anchor and kind of move spots
and do some fishing while everyone wakes
up
little baby rock fish oh there we go
oh look at the spots on that thing that
oh it's a dusky rock fish
we're gonna try a little jog through a
bit of open water to try to get to some
other glaciers
and uh we'll kind of see what happens
we've got about two foot waves here
which ain't much for the boat
[Music]
it's a little bouncy here i'm not sure
how long becca's gonna
be okay with this so we're gonna drop
some
rigs down quickly but we were
thinking
oh that's the biggest irish lord of the
trip
that is the monstrous irish lord
what he just threw up an octopus
i think we need to put up these fishing
rods and go look at some glaciers
there are so many otters here i can see
dozens of otters look at this
oh check it out we got all these seals
resting on the glaciers
well that was pretty cool guys you got
your own little snuggle party going on
over there
snuggle party
well it's been a fun trip but it's time
to give the boat back and get it cleaned
up so
i've got some fish to clean
all right we made it safe and sound back
to the dock i didn't wreck or break
anything
okay who had fun on the boat
[Music]
all right guys come on come on
all right we're just pulling out all of
our camping gear from yesterday getting
it dried and cleaned and then we're
packing up food and getting everything
repacked and going out again tomorrow
well we got a lot done today but now we
are taking the kids over to their
cousin's house
so me and becca can go on a date an
anniversary date
today we are going out to eat coven
style
a schnitzel here with finger potatoes
lingenberry sauce
mega got some rigatoni
now we're sitting here at potter's marsh
and we're watching a family of swans
eating while we
enjoy dessert and second dinner what
about second breakfast
cinnamon texas roadhouse roll with
cinnamon butter
how you like that i got a pavlova for
dessert from the south side grill
oh that is a large brownie
19 years we're up early and at it again
we've washed packed
dried organized sorted and bought
everything we need to do
we're heading down to seward and we are
going to go camping on an
island
all right guys we're here i love you
thanks for driving us happy university
happy anniversary
[Music]
i like them
[Music]
[Music]
all right thanks guys there goes our
boat man that's a ride home
you think we're gonna be okay yeah
all right guys shall we explore a little
bit
hey guys look at this this is the egg of
a giant scape
oh let's see this is the skeleton of a
sea urchin
caramel seeing you see look how he's
going whoa
there's a place we could build a build a
fire and put a tent
actually really done
well guys what do you think is this a
nice little place to get out of the rain
here you guys go it's been raining here
for four days straight
so everything is soaking wet so i'm
gonna bust out all my mad skills here to
see if i
can build a fire in this rain
here pick that up and put it under the
tarp buddy
good job buddy
can you pile this with the other dry
firewood
there we go
[Music]
nice reference tom
got a little bit of a rain awning over
our fire to keep the rain from putting
it out
what's in my tea kettle i'm making the
water
boy wait a minute what's in my bottle
it's more kool-aid you guys are just
like spooning it out like little drug
addicts
okay no more kool-aid no more kool-aid
we're gonna make tonkatsu ramen man
um
we're gonna walk the beach and do a
little beach combing all the way to the
end of the spit
dude that's a pretty good good-looking
mekong it's a semi-con
yeah that's a bone look at that i
thought that was a barnacle
no that's a bone
[Music]
[Music]
yeah i say we go get our sleeping bags
and matt's all pumped up and ready to go
all right guys it's bedtime
well good morning according to my phone
this is six mile per hour winds and 50
degree weather
neither one of those things are true
the boys have gone deep buried real deep
yeah it's windy
foreign
yeah that's fun
good
[Music]
wait that's mine that's yours
you guys want some spam in the tent
you guys hang out here for a little bit
this wind is
cold and aggressive but i gotta start
packing up here the boat's gonna pick us
up in a little bit
watch out tom watch out go get your
boots
well the boat's a little late cause the
weather but they're here they didn't
forget us
wake up but yeah there you go
well the ride back to miller's landing
was a little a little exciting there we
got about three foot waves out in
resurrection bay
we're going to try to go get checked
into our our rental house and
just hang out and enjoy seward for a
little bit
all right
this this is cool let's get our stuff in
and i'll start recharging gopro
batteries because
i burned through them all right guys we
got pizza
oh we got a euro pizza and
an everything pizza oh hey you guys are
here
well guys tomorrow we are going to try
to rent a boat
and take it out fishing so today we're
going to go do the safety walkthrough
and orientation and everything and
we'll see how it goes
all right and thank you all right have a
good night
we just got done checking out the boat
and walk down here and this is where
everyone's snagging for fish i'll be
real quiet like this until a school
salmon comes in and then it's just bam
bam bam every other person's getting it
it's just
it's on and then it's off all right we
need we need to get going home get good
night's sleep guys
all right guys who wants to go catch
some fish yay
[Music]
yeah we're here in the small boat harbor
of seward alaska just putting our way
out to the ocean
and this part makes me so nervous it's
like the high school parking lot this is
where most the crashes happened
all right i think it's time to batten
down the hatches
oh there he is what is it straight up
under the
there you go dusky rockfish what do you
got you got a dusky rock fish
[Music]
all right you got one tom there's a
quill back tom
that's playing more like uh how is it
yeah hell of it
there tommy you got that really hard
you're close you're close
there we go yeah they hurt
puffins tommy so many puffins puppets
yeah you got a good fight on your hand
it's at least we got
lead cod nice that's a pretty good one
too
yeah they're long they're tasty okay
nate you got this this is a pretty good
sized one
what you snapped it in my face there you
go that's a lean [ __ ] buddy that's a
nice one
you take this take the orange rod wow
the halibut rod just got
crushed
[Music]
yeah there's a little little parasite
that goes on the tongue of the fish
nice cod that's fish and chips right
there baby here
good oh that's awesome
look at that eyeball that's awesome tom
he's so small all right let's get him
back let's get him this bullet
poland you got a salmon look at the
color on there that's a beauty
nice salmon buddy that's really pretty
oh man we're getting it all today
yeah something's going on here i'm oh my
god
there we go nice cod oh i got a red one
it's a nice yellow eye yeah i got a nice
fight going on there
that's the problem you guys want to try
another spot just try to mix it up a
little bit
oh look at that little pull up get about
four chase it back up yeah right under
the boat
my brother keeps nailing the little
juvenile salmon
a little a little bigger
we pulled a few out of this spot but
let's try another spot
i got something big here oh it's another
lean cot
oh that's a nice clean cut it does not
bend it like a green link
keep a little tension but jen be gentle
and then
look at that that's cool man what is
that oh that's another rock fish see
that one
in a nice fight there i got it here
whoa that's a that's the biggest yellow
eye of the day
well guys we tore it up we caught more
fish than we could even count and i
think we caught
13 species of fish
man that's pretty cool anyway we got to
get this back to the dock we got a lot
of flaying to do
that's mine holy mackerel look at that
pile of fish
that's a nice orange one 15 20 21
okay we kept 21 we probably left at
least that might be at least that many
i think we're gonna eat some nice fish
tomorrow
guys is that fun yeah it was a blast
yeah
all right guys we're at alaska toy
rental in palmer and i just got
a utv here well six person enclosed cab
utv
perfect for crappy weather like today
how's it going good to see you man where
did my sons go
we're here with the how to alaska family
and the boys are having a ball
we visited last winter and had a good
time so the boys are really stoked to be
back
tommy upstairs upstairs atvs we go
we have a lot of awesome things planned
today we're gonna go atving off into the
bush
we're gonna look for fossils we might
get to do some gold mining
too you get real nervous close to the
longest but it's a good one
we made it
are you ready
you see that a bobcat just ran across
the road
that's the leaks we're in the bushes
i'm so glad you guys came along
[Music]
here
tommy windshield wiper activate
there we go all right guys you ought to
look for fossils
oh yeah look at that it's right there
there
look at right here oh yeah that's a big
one whoa
that's a huge one that was huge
[Music]
that does look like a fossilized
olympics i found one that isn't broken
at all
oh yeah that one's in great shape oh
look behind you
so let's see
yeah look at that that's cool
oh this is one of the most gorgeous
places i've ever hunted for fossils
isn't this great
all the
i'm having a fossils time
is so much fun
check it out we have some gold mines up
ahead these guys are working excavators
and sloosh boxes
i mean in two hours really good
oh there it is that that's pretty
five grand would have been digging out
of this [ __ ] oh my goodness
oh that's cool all right guys hop in one
time
all right guys you ready to find some
more fossils
is the big rocks roll to the bottom yeah
but they hang up in the trees
oh yeah
that's cool
yes reach for me my son
you're almost there you gotta do it oh
you did it
you're safe just take jumps and and then
it's easier to stop yourself
just go and hop like a bunny yes tommy's
gonna do it hop like a buddy
hop hop
tom's down okay careful
don't get going too fast stop nade stop
oh check it out you find one here we go
this is what we're looking for hopefully
i can
get it without busting it
oh too greedy oh
you can see all the guts of it oh
awesome
look at the calcite in there yeah
let's see look at the crystals look at
the krause of crystals
jake found it it's this is no
jake's cool fossil look at that
that is way cool look at that
beautiful absolutely beautiful oh you
can see all the chambers
that's a great one and see the crystals
growing inside the shell
[Music]
wow
here we go again all right hold on tight
everybody
guys there's a creepy boss
hey if you see a nail grab a nail look
at the engine
oh i would love to know the back story
of how this thing
ended up all the way back here oh look
it's an army bus
it says us army bus for official use
only
all right all aboard the school of hard
knocks is now in session
i hope so
[Music]
we're coming up on jake's gold claim
that's a nice setup
yeah look at that
was awesome
yeah now we're talking
i need you to squish this bag up mix up
all that dough in the bag
[Music]
look at that
oh when it's really up everyone wants
some non spiders
nice and warm better
you know why i know the best part
we have had such a ball getting out here
but it is late
i'm exhausted and i will see you guys
in the morning
oh it's cold
for tonight's battles if i was
we're getting ready to do some gold
mining here on jake's
gold claim but one of the biggest
obstacles to mining gold
is getting the wetsuit on
jake's just a little bit fluffy like me
yeah i did that for like two seconds and
my hands are frozen
oh look at that look that golden i found
oh yeah look at that there's a bunch
right there
you gotta be pretty gentle with it
oh my that's impressive
well there you go about an hour hour and
a half of dredging
and about a hundred dollars worth of
gold well the boys and i have had an
absolute ball
hanging out with jake and if you guys
want to see more great outdoor
adventures that are family-friendly
check out
their channel i'll put a link in the
description below but we've got to get
headed home
and we've got a great trail ahead of us
i'm really excited
for the ride back would you guys like to
do this again sometime
yeah the boys have decided that we
should name the utv
appa after the flying buffalo on avatar
this is oppa my flying bicycle
you are fast and furious ride or die
remember
we didn't get rained on last night but
apparently up in the valley above us it
did get rain
the rivers are a little bit dirty and a
little bit higher
than when we crossed the first time so
it's a little bit of a clincher getting
back home
oh you were wearing your rain pants yep
i'm glad we had the window shut on that
[Music]
one
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
all right tommy let me give you a turn
okay yep
[Music]
right
[Music]
all right jake man it was a pleasure
oh my goodness you're more mud than boy
dirty dirty little boy let's go return
this rental and go
see mama it's our last day here in
alaska and
what a beauty me and my dad are gonna
take the boys out to go get some donuts
and uh
we're gonna do a little adventures with
the family and we're gonna go out with
the bank
hey boys then tom
you have a wonderful day i think those
are make a lot of sense
we got mango pineapple chocolate
with some sort of caramel oh these are
huge
coconut in one hand and a mango in the
other that's you're double wielding it
good guys you want to do a little
exploring yeah
well we got the whole crew in the car
and we're going to head off to gerdwood
we're going to go to a zoo
and we're going to go to a zoo
we're here in gerdwood looking for some
lunch and there's a japanese food truck
i'm going really hot on the inside all
right thank you very much
dried tuna fish mayonnaise soy sauce and
little doughy ball with a chunk of
octopus inside
anyone want one
oh there you go it's got the octopus you
got an octopus tentacle in your mouth
oh you can see the little section cups
and everything the octopus kind of goes
good
the octopus tastes like one bit let's go
get some grilled cheese sandwiches now
to finish off lunch
[Music]
that is a good grilled cheese sandwich
that's sourdough bread there
[Music]
all right
[Music]
let's go check out the zoo
all right we're at the alaska wildlife
conservation center it's a little
private zoo just in between gerdwood and
portage we're gonna check it out we've
got a two mile loop here where we just
kind of cruise around and uh
we can stop and see animals come on jade
[Music]
see they're most dark
[Music]
there's some wood bison over there those
are uh elk
there's a caribou right there by the
fence
it was more fun than i expected i like
that it was a drive-through
oh we have so much packing to do
this thing is absolutely chocked full to
the gills
with fish and i still have to give away
two bags of salmon to my sister
oh it's like our luggage just vomited on
my sister's floor look at this
jacob you gonna miss that melanie
it's hard to believe six weeks is over
isn't it really fast
it went by really fast
[Music]
oh look there's all these moths in here
holy crap the whole back seat is covered
in grain moths i better drive with the
windows down becca you're gonna like
this
hello thousands and thousands of green
bots inside
oh look what got delivered while we were
gone
yeah look at that one million
subscribers well guys it's been a lovely
six week adventure i hope you guys
enjoyed this video as much as we enjoyed
filming it
if you want to see more travel and
adventure videos check out our travel
and adventure playlist
and don't forget to click subscribe find
out what one million other people have
already discovered
and come join us every saturday morning
for a new video